now the center game that arises after
the mortar E4 E5 D4 e captures D4 and
queen captures D4 is a very interesting
Dynamic and attacking weapon from the
wild
and some of the top Grand Masters are
playing this as a complete surprise
weapon including X World Championship
Challenger Napoli
the idea is after Knight to C6 and queen
to E3 as you can see I have highlighted
by the arrows
generally what happens is why take out
his coincide pieces and quickly goes on
the Quincy castle where on the
counterpart black is going to do the
same except on the king side
so we have a very fun and aggressive
position just in the opening
and that's why it has been preferred at
all level of chance
well in today's lecture I am going to
present not only a beautiful trap in
this line
but you are also going to witness
one amazing counter trap in this line
which as a black you definitely want to
watch out
[Music]
Now by far if you look at the database
here Knight to F6 is the mainline move
however not everybody is comfortable
about it and the move which frequently
occurred in this line is
B6 which is in fact as per the database
played in roughly 50 000 games
whereupon Black's idea is very obvious
he wants to attack Our Queen with Bishop
to C5
okay white doesn't bother about it so he
continued with Knight to C3
and after Bishop to C5
here comes the move which sets up the
trappy platform and that is
Queen to G3
okay so before we move on I'd like you
to pause this video and think that if
you are black in this position which
move you are going to choose
as there are three good choices
but amongst them only one is right
so take your time and Choose Wisely
okay let's see each python
well if you have preferred the move
Queen to F6 then I'm afraid you straight
away fallen into the white trappy
territory as after just one move Knight
to D5 and suddenly black is losing the
game as
there is a double attack on the table
and unfortunately for black he cannot
defend both of them
and the surprising part is there are
roughly 5 000 people falling for this
the best black can do over here is play
Queen to E5 but now very easy you take
on C7 first king to d8 now you take the
queen and then take the Rook
whereupon at the end result Bishop to B7
Knight captures B6 and Bishop captures
B6 if you carefully count the material
here
white has exchanged plus two points at
just 11th move of the game isn't that
amazing
the second most fascinating trap occurs
if your opponent continue with G6
which at First Sight parries all the
threat but believe me after this white
is forcefully winning
yup if you want you can try it by
yourself I'm showing you right now
the first move is very obvious yup we
play Knight to D5 attacking on C7 if
Bishop to D6 then Bishop to F4 is a very
strong reply
so more or less black has to play the
move D6
and after this
the wonderful move
Queen to C3
continue the white initiative as the
rook in the corner hangs and the only
way to protect it is to play F6
but now another strike happened on the
board
Bishop to B5 attacking the lose Knight
and here it doesn't matter wherever
black plays the bishop let's say Bishop
to D7 unpinning the Knight
can you see the deciding blow
congratulations if you find the sequence
Bishop takes C6 Bishop takes C6 and the
sting in the tail
before
and after this white is winning the
peace in a broad daylight
well the best black and Duo here is
Bishop captures D5 but after Pawn takes
D5 that piece is not going anywhere
and there's a game in the database where
black give this check and after Knight
to E2 and sag the bishop
but after King takes F2 white
comfortably does the artificial castle
and don't forget
he's a completely peace up
well so far we have seen a lot of fun
from the white side
but now it's Blackstone and the third
move Knight to F6 believe it or not but
sets up an amazing counter trap in this
line
so at first sight it looks like black
has made a blunder and can't white can
easily take this pawn and attack The
Rook
well yep he can do it except one problem
that
white has fallen straight away into
black countertrap territory
the trappy sequence start with Rook to
G8 and after Queen to at six
can you see the deciding blow here
well you are absolutely right if you see
the move
Bishop captures F2 bam
what a move
now the obvious enough is you can't take
this bishop as after Knight to G4 you
lose your queen so that's not a possible
and that means white King has to move
and as per the database King to Devon is
by far the most popular choice
but after this black has pretty much
forcing sequence which gives him a
completely upper hand
well recently this happens in a video
game and I just like to show you how
quickly black finish up the white
in the game Black start with D5 opening
up the line against the white king white
take on D5
and now comes the move which you don't
expect Bishop to E6
putting more pressure on the D5 Pawn
so white blocked the file with Bishop to
D2
but indeed after the few exchanges
Knight takes D5 Knight takes D5 and
queen takes D5
black is all set to Castle on the Quint
side and then become hell loose on the
king caught in the center
Why Try to defend his position with
Knight to F3 but after Castle C3
desperately want to take the king out
but nope black didn't give any chance as
he continued with Queen to E4
and now the threat is Bishop to E3
and unfortunately in the game
white played the decisive blunder King
to C1
neutralizing the threat of Bishop to E3
but completely forgotten the next
amazing move
yup Bishop to F5
and the game is a complete corner
the king comes back but this is too
little too late
Queen to C2 check
King to E2
and Bishop to C5 White made the final
mistake of the game B4
whereupon Rook G to E8
highlight how pathetic white position
has become once he has fallen for the
counter trap
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile trap and counter
trap in the center game
remember after Bishop to G5 and the move
Queen to G3
two moves Queen to F6 and G6 leads to
the Trap where Knight web 6 leads to the
amazing counter trap
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will see you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care